Pam got a minute Pamela Anderson accuses
Tim Allen of flashing her on the set of
Home Improvement
our little Pammy and she's the sweetest
girl that's why we love her and the
comedian slamming Anderson's claim Alan
tells E.T in a statement No it never
happened I would never do such a thing
the accusations part of Anderson's new
Memoir love Pamela in the pilot I was
wearing cutoffs you know my tool belts
Thank you Lisa in an excerpt published
by variety the actress recalls her first
day on set Tim is
amazing I mean there's no real words for
him he's hysterical I didn't know until
the day we started the pilot then I had
the job and on day one of filming the
hit 90 sitcom Anderson alleges quote I
walked out of my dressing room and Tim
was in the hallway in his robe he opened
his robe and flashed me quickly
completely naked underneath
at the time Anderson was 23 years old
best known for appearing in Playboy they
called me they wanted me to do a cover
first and they wanted me to be a
playmate and she alleges that after
Allen exposed himself quote he said it
was only fair because he had seen me
naked now we're even I laughed
uncomfortably of course Anderson went on
to star in another TV Mega hit Baywatch
CJ Parker my family's been through a
zillion miles since she left Home
Improvement E.T was on the set when
Anderson reunited with the cast and
there appeared to be only fond memories
of working with Alan Tim hasn't changed
I haven't changed he's just so like
modest about his success and such a real
person and a lot of fun to make fun of
you know poke fun at and you know it's
great it's just a very very light
atmosphere fast forward to 2023 and
Pam's sharing her truth on multiple
platforms she's promoting a memoir if
anybody's watching this go to hell
plus a Netflix documentary Pamela a love
story both debuting January 31st
I want to take control of the narrative
For the First Time The promos tease
Anderson's reaction to renewed focus on
her and ex Tommy Lee's Infamous Scandal
which was dramatized in Hulu's Pam and
Tommy
I block that stone tape out of my life
in order to survive and now that it's
all coming up again I feel sick
Anderson spoken out against the series
that chronicled their roller coaster
romance and subsequent Fallout
wow you are so hot
[Music]
what the hell is this it's always such a
huge responsibility to play someone a
real person particularly with Pamela you
know she's such an icon I really love
her A source told E.T at the time the
on-screen portrayals were very painful
for Anderson and made without her
approval you have to be brave and you
gotta use what you got
why can't we be the heroes in our own
life story
[Music]
foreign